Has Disney found its Goku...already?
Following reports that a Dragon Ball live-action
film is in early development at Disney comes
the news that the studio may already have
their eye on a candidate for the film's leading
role: Ludi Lin, who appeared in last year's
Aquaman.
This news bite comes courtesy of the rumor-mongers
over at We Got This Covered, though, so take
it with a grain of salt.
Lin is reportedly being considered for Goku,
the good-natured and formerly monkey-tailed
extraterrestrial warrior in the highly popular
Japanese manga and anime series of the same
name.
WGTC is reporting that according to its sources,
Lin is currently on the studio's wish list
of potential actors to help usher in a new
iteration of the hit anime franchise.
Said sources state that at this point, it
is just a wish list, however, and there's
no word on whether the actor has actually
been contacted by the studio.
Again, it should be pointed out the report
is in no way confirmed, and should be relegated
to the realm of rumor until such time as official
confirmation comes down the pike.
Lin has slowly seen his star rise over the
last several years, starting with his role
as Zack, the cocky, adrenaline-seeking Black
Ranger in the Lionsgate reboot of the beloved
and campy '90s Power Rangers franchise.
The film underperformed at the box office,
but Lin's prominence on the project helped
propel the Chinese-Canadian star into the
spotlight.
"This is a bad idea!
Okay!
Uh, signals!
Brakes!
I need brakes!
Manual.
MANUAL!
Where are the brakes?!"
Soon after, he appeared as Captain Murk, the
leader of Atlantis' front line army in Aquaman.
He then turned up in a crazy episode of Black
Mirror, "Fighting Vipers", before nabbing
the role of Liu Kang in New Line Cinema's
upcoming Mortal Kombat reboot, which is slated
to hit theaters sometime in 2021.
According to WGTC's sources, the new Dragon
Ball flick will have an exclusively Asian
cast and sport a large budget, a decidedly
different approach to bringing the beloved
anime to the big screen than 20th Century
Fox's 2009 adaptation.
Directed by James Wong and written by Ben
Ramsey, Dragonball Evolution was universally
blasted by critics and fans alike for its
poor writing, weird fight sequences, and white-washed
cast.
The film had a budget of $35 million, and
made about $55 million at the global box office,
making it a pretty egregious flop, especially
for such a spectacularly popular property.
"I am the hope of the universe!
I am the answer to all living things that
cry out for peace!"
There are few franchises as popular worldwide
as Dragon Ball; part hero's journey, part
superpowered action story, part tale of friendship,
the cultural influence of the anime has stretched
far beyond its humble beginnings as a serialized
manga, which was first published in 1984.
Since its initial incarnation, the Dragon
Ball franchise has spawned a number of manga
spin-offs, several big and small screen anime
adaptations, theme park attractions, a series
of soundtracks, companion books, collectible
cards, table top games, video games, and even
a pop-up cafe.
With all of that to its name, it shouldn't
be surprising that it's one of the highest-grossing
media franchises of all time, and one that
major studios definitely want to try to cash
in on.
Following the catastrophe that was the 2009
live action adaptation, though, it seemed
highly unlikely that Goku and his unforgettable
enemies like Frieza [FREE-zuh] and Janemba
[juh-NEHM-buh] would ever see the light of
live-adaptation again.
Knowing how badly it could go wrong, some
of Dragon Ball's most die-hard fans even started
to believe that no film at all was better
than another bad one.
Thanks to the Disney/Fox merger earlier this
year, however, everything has changed.
Disney has become an absolute juggernaut for
producing high-value IP-based franchises;
the studio that managed to assemble Marvel,
Star Wars, and Pixar under its roof before
moving on to Fox has been so successful in
converting established IP to box office gold
that it's got other studios scrambling to
figure out how to to replicate its model with
their own projects.
Fox Studios has seen many of its in-development
movies scrapped since the merger, but that
doesn't mean that the Mouse House isn't interested
in welcoming Fox's more powerful properties
into the fold.
With Dragon Ball's massive cultural clout,
it seems highly likely that Disney will, at
the very least, consider bringing this beloved
anime universe to life.
Until we get some kind of actual announcement,
though, we'll just have to hope that there's
something to all of the buzz, and for our
money, Lin would make an absolutely amazing
Goku.
We'll keep our eyes peeled for any official
word, and keep you up to speed.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.